From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Emmanuel Dzotsi, sitting in for Ira Glass. So about two months ago, I left work in the middle of the day and joined about 100 million people worldwide in a very particular kind of prayer.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Emmanuel Dzotsi，代班Ira Glass。大约两个月前，我在中午离开工作岗位，加入全球约一亿人的行列，进行了一种非常特别的祈祷。
Now, I wish I could tell you that I was praying for a fix to any of the world's problems. But I wasn't. Instead, I was standing in a crowded bar in downtown Brooklyn, screaming my lungs off for my favorite British soccer team, Arsenal Football Club.
我多希望能告诉你们，我是在祈祷世界上的某个问题得到解决。但我没有。相反，我正站在布鲁克林市中心一家拥挤的酒吧里，为我最喜欢的英国足球队——阿森纳足球俱乐部——声嘶力竭地呐喊。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Come on, Arsenal. Come on!
加油，阿森纳。加油！
Arsenal! Arsenal! Arsenal! Arsenal! Arsenal!
阿森纳！阿森纳！阿森纳！阿森纳！阿森纳！
Arsenal are my hometown London team. A lot of the fans in the bar are just like me. There's quite a few Brits, lots of Black 30-somethings, probably because when I was a kid, I swear, Arsenal catfished an entire generation of us into supporting them. They played some of the best soccer I've ever seen with a team full of all these Black legends. They went an entire season without losing a game in the British Premier League.
阿森纳是我伦敦家乡的球队。酒吧里很多球迷和我一样。有好几个英国人，还有许多三十出头的黑人，大概是因为我小时候，我发誓，阿森纳“钓鱼”欺骗了我们整整一代人去支持他们。他们踢出我所见过的最精彩的足球，球队里全是黑人传奇球星。他们在英超联赛中曾整个赛季保持不败。
And then they stopped winning and decided to break my heart every year for the next 20 years. My brothers and sisters in Christ, I have seen some things. I've seen us lose by record margins. I've seen two separate seasons derailed by horrific, "Why did you show that in slow motion?" leg breaks. I saw one of my favorite players leave us for our rivals, beat us to win a trophy, and then thank us sarcastically afterwards.
然后他们不再赢球，决定在接下来的20年里每年都伤透我的心。我在基督里的兄弟姐妹们，我可是见过大世面的。我见过我们以创纪录的分差惨败。我见过两个赛季因为恐怖的、那种“你们为什么要回放慢动作？”的断腿伤病而脱轨。我见过我最喜欢的球员之一投奔对手，击败我们夺冠，事后还讽刺地感谢我们。
Arsenal have sometimes upset me so much that, for the sake of the people I love, I have had to deliberately skip games the day of family events, just because I don't want to look stricken in our photos. But then three years ago, lots of things just kind of started to go our way. We finished that season as the second-best team in England. And since then, it just feels like we've been inching ever closer to becoming winners again.
阿森纳有时让我非常沮丧，为了爱我的人，我不得不刻意避开家庭活动当天的比赛，因为我不想在合影里显得一脸愁容。但三年前，很多事情开始好转。我们以英格兰第二好的成绩结束了那个赛季。从那时起，感觉我们离重回巅峰越来越近了。
We've got this young coach my mum says is far too pretty to be so smart. We have a star player who-- I don't know-- I love like he's my own son. And this most recent season, we went on this miraculous run in European soccer's biggest competition, the Champions League-- I'm talking defensive masterclasses, big upsets, players scoring the kind of goals they've never scored before in their entire lives.
我们有一位年轻教练，我妈妈说他长得太帅了，不该那么聪明。我们有一位明星球员——怎么说呢——我像爱自己的儿子一样爱他。就在最近这个赛季，我们在欧洲足球最高级别的赛事——欧冠联赛中打出了奇迹般的表现——我说的是教科书式的防守、惊天大冷门、球员们踢进了他们一生中从未进过的球。
It felt like the conditions at that moment for Arsenal were perfect. We had the right players, the right coach. And some of our opponents, they were having an uncharacteristically bad year-- which brings us to the day I left work to go to the bar. We were now at the end of the season in maybe the biggest Arsenal game in 20 years.
当时感觉阿森纳的状况堪称完美。我们有合适的球员，合适的教练。而且我们的一些对手经历了反常的糟糕一年——这把我们带回了我请假去酒吧的那一天。那可能是阿森纳20年来最重要的一场比赛，当时已经是赛季末了。
Arsenal were playing a French team, Paris Saint-Germain, in the semi-finals, a team we knew we could beat. In fact, we'd beaten them earlier in the season. All we had to do was do it again. And walking around the bar that day before the game, I heard two different feelings from people. The first was joy and optimism. Like, wow, we could actually win this. Then there was the second, sort of nagging feeling, which was people experiencing how great this moment was and feeling dread because of it.
阿森纳在半决赛中对阵法国球队巴黎圣日耳曼，这支球队我们知道可以击败。事实上，我们在这个赛季早些时候已经赢过他们。我们要做的只是再做一次。在那天比赛开始前，我在酒吧里走动时，听到人们有两种不同的感受。第一种是喜悦和乐观。觉得，哇，我们真的能赢。第二种是某种令人担忧的感觉，人们感受到这一刻是多么美好，却因此感到恐惧。
Nervous.
紧张。
You look nervous.
你看上去很紧张。
Because I'm a realist.
因为我是现实主义者。
Say more about that.
多说说看。
This is a good opportunity, but I feel like we're at the tail end of our good opportunities. It's been good opportunities now for, like, three years. And I think we're on the other side of the curve.
这是一个好机会，但我感觉我们已经处于好机会的末尾了。像这样的好机会已经持续了大约三年。我觉得我们已经过了巅峰期。
Like, it's ending, this good period-- it's been too good for too long.
就像，这个美好的时期要结束了——它已经好得太久了。
I'm waiting for the other shoe to drop or other hat to drop, whatever that saying is.
我在等另一只鞋掉下来，或者是另一顶帽子掉下来，不管那句谚语是怎么说的。
This feeling-- that if we didn't win this trophy right now, that it might never happen for this group of players-- was something I heard a lot. Next year, we could lose some players. And the other teams could be better than they were this season. There are just too many unknowns, and that was making so many Arsenal fans nervous. Maybe this was as good as things were going to get.
这种感觉——如果我们现在不赢得这个奖杯，这批球员可能再也没有机会了——我听到了很多。明年，我们可能会失去一些球员。其他球队可能会比这个赛季表现得更好。有太多未知的因素，这让很多阿森纳球迷感到紧张。也许这就是我们所能达到的最好水平了。
There's a name for a period like this. It's called a championship window, a period of time when all the conditions for your team to win are just right. And as this game was about to begin, I looked around and was like, oh, that's where Arsenal are. It felt like all of us gathered there, had this front-row seat to something historic, something we would definitely tell our kids about one day.
像这样的时期有一个名字。它被称为“夺冠窗口期”，即球队获胜的所有条件都恰到好处的一段时间。随着比赛即将开始，我环顾四周，心想，哦，这就是阿森纳所处的阶段。感觉我们聚集在这里的所有人，都有幸前排见证了某些历史性的时刻，某些我们将来一定会告诉孩子们的事。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
And that's what today's episode is about-- that period of time. So this week, while the boss man is away and I am in charge and the conditions are just right, I come to you with stories about championship windows, and not just ones that are about sports. I'm talking championship windows for your body, for your feelings, stories of people trying desperately to seize their moment and finally win their own personal championship.
这就是今天节目的主题——那段时期。所以本周，当老板不在，我负责，且条件恰到好处时，我带给大家关于夺冠窗口的故事，而且不仅仅是关于体育的。我指的是你身体的夺冠窗口，你感受的夺冠窗口，关于人们拼命想要抓住那一刻并最终赢得个人冠军的故事。
So stay with us.
请留在我们身边。
It's This American Life, today's program, Championship Window. We've now reached Act One-- Pregnant, Pause. So this story is about a championship window that billions of people around the world have passed through, though many of those folks have completely missed it. Connie Wang was in that category. She has the story.
这里是《美国生活》，今天的节目名为《夺冠窗口》。我们现在进入第一幕——怀孕，停顿。这个故事关于全球数十亿人经历过的夺冠窗口，尽管许多人完全错过了它。Connie Wang就属于这一类。她来讲这个故事。
During my first pregnancy, I kept a log of all the weird things that happened to my body, beyond the obvious ones, like a growing belly and swollen ankles. These changes were random and sudden and almost sinister, as if my body was messing with me just for the fun of it. My gums bled. I broke a tooth. My boobs began to itch from the inside. Varicose veins sprouted all over my legs-- and other places too. The pinky on my right hand clicked each time I bent it. And my right foot-- and only my right foot-- was always hot.
在我第一次怀孕期间，我记录了身体发生的所有奇怪事情，除了明显的肚子变大和脚踝浮肿之外。这些变化是随机的、突然的，几乎是恶意的，好像我的身体只是为了好玩在折磨我。我的牙龈出血。我崩掉了一颗牙。我的胸部开始从内而外发痒。静脉曲张在我的腿上——以及其他部位——蔓延开来。我右手的尾指每次弯曲都会发出咔嗒声。还有我的右脚——仅仅是右脚——总是发烫。
There were some nice things that happened too. My horrible acid reflux disappeared, and the back pain that I've had for five years also stopped bothering me. When I read this list to my doctor, he told me that everything I was experiencing was perfectly normal. He explained that some of the symptoms were so the fetus could better leach the nutrients, calcium, and blood out of me and into it. The other elements were because my body was breaking itself apart so that it could eventually extrude a whole other body.
当然也有一些好的变化。我可怕的胃酸倒流消失了，困扰我五年的背痛也不再烦扰我。当我把这张清单读给医生听时，他告诉我，我经历的一切都完全正常。他解释说，有些症状是为了让胎儿能更好地从我身上摄取营养、钙质和血液。其他情况是因为我的身体正在分解自己，以便最终能孕育出另一个完整的身体。
Then my doctor said, after the delivery, all the pregnancy hormones that made me so pliable and scrambled would leave my body, and my bones, joints, organs, and muscles would find their way home again and lock back into place. Most of the things on my list would disappear, but some things might remain. Among everything on the list, it was my back pain-- rather, the lack of back pain-- that I wished would be a forever thing.
然后医生说，分娩后，所有让我变得柔软、混乱的孕期荷尔蒙都会离开我的身体，我的骨骼、关节、器官和肌肉会找到回家的路并重新归位。清单上的大多数症状会消失，但有些可能会留下。在清单上的所有项目中，我的背痛——更准确地说是背痛的消失——是我希望成为永久状态的事。
I had tweaked it in my 20s during a move. And for five years, it kept me from doing basic things, like tying my shoes without sitting down on the floor, or even leaning over the sink to brush my teeth. Pregnant, even with a massive belly and jello legs, I could lower myself onto the floor to squat without my back giving out. It would be amazing if the pain never returned.
我在20多岁搬家时扭伤了背。五年以来，这让我无法做基本的事情，比如不用坐在地上就系不好鞋带，甚至不能弯腰在水槽前刷牙。怀孕时，即使挺着巨大的肚子、腿软无力，我也能蹲下而背部不会垮掉。如果疼痛永远不再复发，那该多棒。
My doctor said that was unlikely, but my mom actually had a whole theory about how exactly to keep my back pain away. She told me I should actively take advantage of the window of time right after I gave birth, before my body locked back into place. She wanted me to zuo yue zi-- to do postpartum confinement.
医生说这不太可能，但我妈妈其实有一套关于如何保持背痛不复发的完整理论。她告诉我应该积极利用产后那段身体还没归位的窗口期。她想让我“坐月子”——进行产后修养。
The word confinement sounds worse than it actually is. Technically, you are not actually confined. There are no locks or constraints, which is extraordinary when you hear how draconian the rules of confinement are, according to traditional Chinese standards-- no cold foods, including cold beverages, no spicy foods, no strong flavors, and no deviating from the strict diet. No bathing, no washing your hair, no open windows or air conditioning, no leaving your home, no bare feet, no exercising, no housework, no reading, no TV, and absolutely no crying. And you have to do this for at least 30 days.
“月子”这个词听起来比实际情况要糟糕。从技术上讲，你并没有真正被关起来。没有锁也没有限制，当你听说根据中国传统标准，“坐月子”的规矩有多严苛时，这简直不可思议——不吃冷食，包括冷饮；不吃辣；不吃重口味；严格遵循食谱。不能洗澡，不能洗头，不能开窗或开空调，不能出门，不能光脚，不能运动，不能做家务，不能看书，不能看电视，绝对不能哭。而且你必须这样做至少30天。
This kind of methodical postpartum bed rest is actually pretty common in many cultures where new moms receive a lot help, especially right after birth-- so, obviously, not in America. And the promise of confinement-- in Chinese culture, at least-- is that at the end, not only will your body heal from the delivery, but if you really do it right, you can guide your body back together in a way that's even better than before you were pregnant.
这种有条理的产后卧床休息，在许多新妈妈能得到很多帮助的文化中其实相当普遍，尤其是在刚生完孩子后——所以，很明显，在美国不是这样。而且在中国文化中，“坐月子”的承诺在于，到最后，不仅你的身体会从分娩中恢复，如果你真的做得对，你还可以引导你的身体以一种比怀孕前更好的状态回归。
If you do it right, my mom told me, you could fix your back. It didn't have to be that bad, she said, especially if you got rid of the outdated rules invented before germ theory and indoor plumbing. I could wash my hair and watch TV. Still, no, I wasn't going to do it. I had always found confinement to be sort of offensive. Treating a woman as a delicate, breakable, incapable doll seemed insulting. I considered myself to be the exact opposite.
妈妈告诉我，如果做得对，你可以治好你的背。她说，这没那么糟，特别是如果你去掉了那些在细菌理论和室内管道发明之前就有的过时规矩。我可以洗头看电视。尽管如此，不，我还是不想这么做。我一直觉得坐月子有点冒犯人。把女人当作一个脆弱、易碎、无能的洋娃娃对待，似乎是一种侮辱。我自认为恰恰相反。
Frankly, I was surprised that my mom was so into me doing confinement. She raised me to be independent and nonconformist, just like her. She insisted that I should always have my own bank account, even as a fourth grader, that as a woman, I should always be loud and precise at everything I did, that I shouldn't just go along with a thing just because everyone else was doing it. The result of all of this is that now I am a stubborn person who loves to believe I'm right, especially when it contradicts common sense.
坦白说，我很惊讶我妈妈这么热衷于让我坐月子。她把我培养成一个像她一样的独立且不随波逐流的人。她坚持认为，哪怕在四年级时，我也应该有自己的银行账户；作为女性，无论做什么事都要响亮且精准；我不应该因为大家都这样做就盲目跟从。这一切的结果是，我现在是一个固执的人，喜欢相信自己是对的，特别是在与常识相悖的时候。
Here's an example. My whole life, I never exercised and was even kind of proud of it, even though doctors and physical therapists told me my back would never fully recover unless I did. But there was just something so uncool about doing little squats in my living room or spending $30 on a Pilates lesson-- $50? How much is Pilates? My mom is like this too. She refuses to look at maps because she's made a decision that she can't read them, which is absurd because she's an accountant who also once edited engineering manuals.
举个例子。我这辈子从不运动，甚至还以此为荣，尽管医生和物理治疗师都告诉我，除非我运动，否则我的背永远不会完全康复。但在客厅里做深蹲，或者花30美元上普拉提课——50美元？普拉提多少钱？——感觉太不酷了。我妈妈也是这样。她拒绝看地图，因为她认定自己看不懂，这很荒谬，因为她是一位曾编辑过工程手册的会计师。
Anyways, my mom admitted that she had been skeptical of confinement too. She'd actually skipped it the second time she had a kid, my little sister, something she eventually regretted. According to mom, the benefits of confinement were a mystery until she tried to go without. I should save myself the trial and error and just listen to her.
无论如何，我妈承认她以前也怀疑坐月子。她第二次生我妹妹时其实跳过了这一步，后来她很后悔。据妈妈说，坐月子的好处是个谜，直到她尝试了不坐才明白。我应该省去试错的过程，听她的就好。
Of course, I didn't listen to her.
当然，我没听她的。
I gave birth via emergency C-section 10 days after I was due. When a nurse admired how quickly my wounds were healing, it activated the overachiever in me, and I became determined to prove how talented I was at healing. When the doctor said she wanted to see me walk around the hospital ward once in the next 24 hours, I did it three times. When she told me to wait two weeks before bending over or climbing stairs, I did it as soon as I got home.
我在预产期后10天进行了紧急剖宫产。当护士称赞我的伤口愈合得很快时，激活了我体内“优等生”的开关，我决心证明自己有多擅长恢复。当医生说她希望我在接下来的24小时内下床走动一次时，我走了三次。当她告诉我弯腰或爬楼梯前要等两周时，我一回家就做了。
I felt all sorts of messed up, but also proud of myself for being able to do it. Plus, my back was miraculously still pain free. There's actually a video of me on my first day back home with my newborn in my arms, lowering myself onto the concrete sidewalk so my greyhound could sniff my kid's head. I posted this video on Instagram, and I remember beaming with pride as more experienced moms commented, squatting? Already?
我感到浑身不对劲，但也为自己能做到而感到自豪。而且，我的背奇迹般地依然不痛。事实上，有一段视频显示我刚回家的第一天，抱着新生儿，慢慢蹲在水泥人行道上，好让我的灰狗闻闻孩子的头。我把这段视频发到Instagram上，我记得当更有经验的妈妈们评论说“蹲下？这么快？”时，我因自豪而发光。
Meanwhile, my mom was side-eyeing me, passive-aggressively urging me to sit back down, to put socks on, and to quit drinking so much cold seltzer and drink some bean porridge instead. It took two weeks for my back pain to return. And when it came back, it was so much worse than it was before I was pregnant. I had to lean against the walls to walk down the hallway and often found myself stuck on the floor, flat on my back, dialing my husband, who was on the other side of the house, for help.
与此同时，我妈妈斜着眼看我，冷嘲热讽地催我坐回去，穿上袜子，别喝那么多冷气泡水，喝点红豆粥。两周后我的背痛复发了。当它回来时，比我怀孕前严重得多。我不得不靠着墙走过走廊，经常发现自己瘫在地上，平躺着，给屋子另一头的丈夫打电话求助。
I figured out a way to leverage my baby out of his bassinet with a baby blanket and a hinging movement so I didn't have to bend over when I was picking him up. It was infuriating. It was bullshit that my pain had come back even worse. It wasn't just my back. My pelvic floor was barely functioning. My C-section scar continued to burn for months after my surgery.
我想出一个办法，用婴儿毯和铰链式的动作把宝宝从摇篮里带出来，这样我就不用弯腰抱他了。这真让人愤怒。我的疼痛复发得更严重简直是胡扯。不仅仅是我的背。我的盆底肌几乎无法运作。剖宫产伤口在手术后几个月里一直隐隐作痛。
Taunting me was the fact that I somehow grew half an inch, evidence that my body had changed in a measurable way, just not at all in the way that I wanted it to. I had happened upon a magical window of opportunity and completely whiffed it. I had been given a chance at getting better, and instead, I'd used this time to get even worse. Fast forward four years, and I got a second chance. I got pregnant again. And, like before, my back pain disappeared. I wasn't going to mess it up this time. So I set up the guest bedroom for my mom and cleared my calendar for 30 days.
最讽刺的是我竟然长高了半英寸，这证明我的身体确实发生了可测量的变化，只是完全不是我想要的那种。我曾碰巧遇到了一个神奇的机遇之窗，却完全挥霍了它。我曾获得一个康复的机会，却利用这段时间让身体变得更糟。快进四年，我有了第二次机会。我再次怀孕了。和以前一样，我的背痛消失了。这次我绝不会搞砸。所以我为妈妈布置了客房，并清空了我接下来30天的行程。
I figured the first day would be the easiest. After all, I was in the hospital. I would wear socks and rest as much as I could. My first test of willpower was one hour after I gave birth. A nurse offered me ice chips, which I declined-- against the rules. But a parade of medical interns kept showing up with ice water.
我想第一天是最容易的。毕竟我在医院里。我会穿上袜子，尽可能多休息。我的第一个意志力测试是在产后一小时。护士给了我冰片，我拒绝了——违规的。但一群实习医生不断拿着冰水出现。
Do you have room temperature water? I would respond in a saintly and goodly way. By the fourth or fifth time, I began to mutter my question through a scowl, asking for my disgusting lukewarm water. My husband would absentmindedly swish his own bottle around. And the ringing peals of ice against metal sounded like the beginning of an argument to me, which was, if you're keeping track, also against the rules.
“有常温水吗？”我会以一种圣洁且友好的方式回应。到第四或第五次时，我开始皱着眉头咕哝我的要求，想要那令人作呕的温水。我丈夫会漫不经心地晃动他自己的瓶子。冰块撞击金属的声音听起来像是争吵的前奏，顺便提一下，这也违反了规定。
My doctor told me I had to do two laps around the ward before I could be discharged, which also bumped up against confinement rules. So instead of pushing myself to do more, I pushed myself to do the bare minimum. I took my first lap nearly 24 hours after she had asked, and it took me nearly 30 minutes to complete the small circuit.
医生告诉我，出院前我必须绕病房走两圈，这也与坐月子的规矩相抵触。所以我不强迫自己多做，而是强迫自己只做最起码的事情。我在她要求后的近24小时才走了第一圈，绕这个小圈花了近30分钟。
At home, my husband played with our three-year-old while my mother showed me that she had stocked the kitchen with special confinement food-- overnight oats, hard-boiled eggs, blueberries, and raw cashews. There was a crucible of babaofan, a porridge made of red beans, jujubes, and goji berries that would help me replenish my hemoglobin count.
在家时，丈夫陪着三岁的孩子玩，我妈向我展示她已经在厨房储备了特别的月子餐——隔夜燕麦、煮鸡蛋、蓝莓和生腰果。还有一个装着八宝粥的锅，那是用红豆、红枣和枸杞做的，可以帮我补充血红蛋白。
The taste was pleasant and mild, and I was to have it any time I was thirsty, which was constantly. I ate my weird spread of nuts and fruits, porridge and eggs, like some kind of storybook bear who lives inside of a cottage, and found myself oddly satisfied. Maybe confinement was less like a prison and more like an omakase, where you give yourself over to the will of the sushi chef for the sake of your own enjoyment.
味道不错且温和，口渴时我就喝，一直都很渴。我像童话里住在小屋里的熊一样，吃着那些奇怪的坚果、水果、粥和鸡蛋，竟感到莫名满足。也许坐月子与其说是监狱，不如说是主厨发办，为了自己的享受，你把自己交给寿司师傅去安排。
I had been worried about how I would manage all the sitting. At first, I had the TV on all the time, playing in the background as a matter of habit. But then I found myself going hours without paying attention to whatever was on and just staring at my sleeping baby without thinking about anything in particular. I felt pretty proud of myself for all this nothing. I had eaten vats of beans. The couch had a me-shaped dent in it. I never even thought about my back. It never bothered me even once. I must be healing so well.
我一直担心怎么熬过所有的久坐。起初，我习惯性地让电视一直开着当作背景音。但后来我发现自己可以几个小时不去看电视内容，只是盯着睡着的宝宝，脑子里什么也不想。我为自己能做到“什么都不做”感到自豪。我吃了好几罐豆子。沙发上留下了我的坐印。我从未想过背痛。它一次都没打扰过我。我一定恢复得很好。
And so one day during the second week, I decided to pick up all the toys on the floor of my son's room while my baby napped. And then I decided I wanted to go see what it would look like if I moved the lamp from the left side of the kitchen to the right, and then what the bookshelf would look like if I separated the nonfiction from the fiction. I snuck a mini ice cream cone and ate it in one bite and then ate four more.
所以第二周的一天，趁宝宝午睡时，我决定捡起儿子房间地上的玩具。然后我又决定去看看，如果把厨房的灯从左边挪到右边会是什么样，再看看如果把非虚构类书籍和虚构类分开，书架会是什么样。我偷吃了一个迷你冰淇淋甜筒，一口吃掉，接着又吃了四个。
My mom noticed me puttering around the house and told me I should go sit down. I rolled my eyes but went back to my perch on the couch. Later that day, I went to the bathroom and noticed that I was bleeding more than usual and the color was off. I took my blood pressure, and it was higher than it's ever been. I found my mom, who was napping with the baby. And I told her I didn't feel good and that I was scared, which made me feel worse and even more scared.
我妈注意到我在屋里忙活，让我去坐下。我翻了个白眼，但还是回到了我的沙发位上。那天晚些时候，我去洗手间，注意到出血比平时多，颜色也不对。我测了血压，是有史以来最高的。我找到了正在陪宝宝睡觉的妈妈，告诉她我感觉不好，我很害怕，这让我感觉更糟，更害怕了。
And so I started crying because I was like, this is it. I have internal bleeding. I have preeclampsia-- no, no post-eclampsia. I'm bleeding out. I thought I was rearranging some books when, really, I was signing my own death certificate. I panic-called my doctor. And while I was on hold, I used my mom's phone to call my sister, who's also a doctor. And everyone told me that the bleeding was fairly normal. As for the elevated blood pressure, I was likely just having a panic attack.
于是我开始哭，因为我想，就是这样了。我内出血了。我有子痫前期——不，不，产后子痫。我要失血过多了。我以为自己只是在整理书籍，实际上，我是在签署自己的死亡证明。我惊慌失措地打给医生。在等待接通时，我用妈妈的手机打给同样是医生的姐姐。每个人都告诉我，这种情况其实很正常。至于血压升高，我可能只是惊恐发作了。
I suddenly realized how fragile I was, both physically and mentally, which was a new thing for me to accept. I had hated the idea of confinement because it meant being treated like a weak and broken person. But that is what childbirth does. It breaks your body. Practicing confinement acknowledges that truth, which I was discovering is a much better option than ignoring it. I returned to my couch divot with a new resolve.
我突然意识到自己在身体和心理上是多么脆弱，这对我来说是一个需要接受的新事物。我曾讨厌坐月子的概念，因为它意味着被当作一个虚弱、破碎的人来对待。但这就是分娩对你做的事。它打破了你的身体。练习坐月子承认了这一事实，我发现这比无视它是一个好得多的选择。我带着新的决心回到了我的沙发坑里。
Two weeks later, I was officially done. And-- da, da, da-- confinement worked. My back felt great. My C-section scar was almost totally healed. Compared to my first time, my body was working a thousand times better. The biggest change in those 30 days, though, wasn't to my body. It was to my mind. I was calmer and happier, but I was also less stubborn. I had new proof that sometimes it did make sense to just go along with the thing everyone else was telling me to do.
两周后，我正式出关了。而且——嗒嗒嗒——坐月子有效。我的背感觉好极了。剖宫产伤口几乎完全愈合。相比第一次，我的身体运作状况好了千倍。不过，这30天里最大的变化不是身体，而是心境。我更冷静、更快乐，也没那么固执了。我有新的证据表明，有时盲目听从别人告诉我的话确实是有意义的。
So a few weeks after confinement ended, when I felt the tiniest twinge in my back that would usually signal the beginning of another bout of horrible pain, I tried something else. Instead of just taking Advil and hoping it'd go away, like I used to, I signed up for a physical therapy workshop and started doing little squats in my living room. Old Connie would have never done this. I'm still doing them.
所以，坐月子结束几周后，当我感到背部出现了一丝细微的刺痛——这通常预示着另一轮可怕的疼痛即将来临——我尝试了别的方法。我没有像以前那样只吃止痛药并祈祷它消失，而是报名参加了一个物理治疗研讨会，开始在客厅里做深蹲。旧的Connie绝对不会这么做。我现在还在坚持。
A year later, I tie my shoes with ease and brush my teeth, no problem. So shout-out to my mom and Chinese confinement-- I bow down to both of you. And I don't even have to hold onto anything to do it.
一年后，我系鞋带、刷牙都很轻松，完全没问题。所以，为我妈妈和中国的坐月子点赞——我向你们致敬。而且我甚至不需要扶着什么东西就能做到。
That's writer Connie Wang. The story was produced by Diane Wu and, we first got the idea to do it from Aaron Reiss. You can read more about Connie and her mum in her book, Oh My Mother!
以上是作家Connie Wang。这个故事由Diane Wu制作，我们最初是从Aaron Reiss那里得到的灵感。你可以在她的书《噢，我妈妈！》(Oh My Mother!) 中阅读更多关于Connie和她妈妈的故事。
Coming up, a group of people I can only describe as cursed try to change their fortunes and, well, I tell you about something that's made being in the office a little awkward. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一群我只能描述为被诅咒的人试图改变他们的命运，嗯，我还要告诉你们一件事，它让办公室里的氛围变得有点尴尬。节目继续，稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Emmanuel Dzotsi, filling in for Ira Glass. Today's program is called Championship Window, stories about trying to achieve their goals in that brief moment where everything is possible. We've reached Act Two, Cry Hard with a Vengeance.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Emmanuel Dzotsi，代班Ira Glass。今天的节目叫《夺冠窗口》，讲述的是人们试图在一切皆有可能的短暂时刻实现目标的故事。我们现在进入第二幕——苦难反击战。
This next story is about a man who might be in a championship window. It's actually a guy you've probably heard on the podcast version of this show more than any other person besides Ira.
下一个故事关于一个可能正处于夺冠窗口的男人。其实，他就是除了Ira之外，你们在我们的播客中听到次数最多的那个人。
A quick warning-- there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show.
一个小提醒——今天的节目中包含未消音的脏话。
That is my coworker, Seth Lind, the guy who voices the warnings before our sweary episodes. We actually sit next to each other in the office. He's sensitive and kind, has this great sense of humor. He is the only one at work, I think, who laughs at all of my dad jokes. Did I mention that he's kind? Anyways, there's this one other thing about Seth, which is that he never cries.
那是我的同事，Seth Lind，那个在我们粗口集之前负责录制警告声的人。我们在办公室其实坐在一起。他敏感、善良，幽默感极佳。我想他是公司里唯一一个会为我的冷笑话捧场的人。我提到过他很善良吗？无论如何，Seth还有一点，就是他从不哭。
I mean, I have cried.
我是说，我哭过。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I have cried. But in thinking about the time-- I can remember two times I cried. I remember crying after a breakup in 2008. And I remember crying when watching a documentary when a child reached his artistic potential. And that moment overcame me.
我哭过。但在回顾过去时——我记得有两次我哭了。我记得2008年失恋后我哭了。我还记得看一部纪录片时，当一个孩子达到他的艺术潜能时我哭了。那一刻我被感动了。
And so when I say I don't cry, it means I have cried, but I don't really know I could anymore.
所以当我说是“不哭”时，意思是虽然我哭过，但我不知道自己是否还能再哭。
Seth used to cry when he was a child, but the breakup and the documentary are the only times he remembers crying as an adult. And both of those were extremes. The breakup was very, very sad. And the documentary, which was about the children of sex workers in Calcutta, that was very, very triumphant.
Seth小时候会哭，但失恋和那部纪录片是他作为成年人唯一记得哭过的时候。那两次都是极端情况。失恋是非常、非常悲伤的。而关于加尔各答性工作者子女的那部纪录片，则是非常、非常令人振奋的。
Besides that, though, I think it's actually easier to talk about the stuff that Seth hasn't cried at. He didn't cry when his grandparents died, didn't cry when he saw his wife in her dress on their wedding day. He doesn't remember if he cried when his first kid was born, but definitely didn't cry when the second was. Seth's wife thinks it's odd and a little bit sad that he doesn't cry. And Seth, he regards it as a personal failing, wishes he could be more like other people.
除此之外，我认为谈论Seth“没哭”过的事情反而更容易。他祖父母去世时他没哭，婚礼那天看到妻子穿婚纱时他也没哭。他不记得大儿子出生时自己有没有哭，但小儿子出生时肯定没哭。Seth的妻子觉得他不哭很奇怪，也有一点悲伤。而Seth，他将其视为个人失败，希望自己能像其他人一样。
My father-in-law will cry at most goodbyes in a really sweet way.
我岳父在大多数离别时都会以一种非常甜蜜的方式哭泣。
Oh, just like, anytime you--
哦，就是，无论什么时候……
Yeah, like we're gathering. And it's just like, OK, I'll see you in a month or whatever. He's very wistful and sad to part because of a love of being together. And I can't fathom that, the idea of being, like, overcome in that moment. I'm envious. It seems wonderful and so foreign to me.
是的，就像我们聚会要结束，或是“好的，下个月见”之类的时候。他总是非常伤感，因为热爱相聚而对离别感到难过。我无法理解那种在当下被情感淹没的感觉。我很羡慕。那对我来说看起来很美妙，又如此陌生。
Seth knows that thing you're thinking, Wow, a man unable or unwilling to cry-- how newsworthy. But he has a theory about why he is the way he is.
Seth知道你们在想什么：“哇，一个不能或不愿哭的男人——真有新闻价值。”但他对自己为何如此有一个理论。
When he was 15, Seth had to get a pacemaker to regulate his heartbeat. And this pacemaker, it was this model that increased his heart rate based on body motion or exercise. But it didn't speed up his heart rate based on his emotion. So anytime Seth was angry or sad or anxious, his heart rate stayed exactly the same.
Seth 15岁时安装了一个起搏器来调节心率。这个起搏器可以根据身体运动或锻炼来加快他的心率。但它不会根据他的情绪加快心率。所以无论Seth是愤怒、悲伤还是焦虑，他的心率都保持完全不变。
And so my theory is that that is related to not crying, that the physiological phenomenon of being overcome by emotion is limited by this machine.
所以我推测这与不哭有关，即被情绪淹没的生理现象受到了这台机器的限制。
It-- [LAUGHS] It sounds like what you're saying is you don't have a heart.
这……[笑声] 这听起来像是你在说你没有心脏。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like, metaphorically-- like that's why you're not crying.
就像，隐喻上——这就是你为什么不哭的原因。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes. I agree with you, Emmanuel. I mean, I do have a heart. It's just electrically regulated.
是的。我同意你的观点，Emmanuel。我是说，我确实有心脏。只是它是电调节的。
This is, for the record, not scientifically correct, which Seth knows. Pacemakers don't affect your ability to cry. But a couple months ago, Seth found out he needed to have open-heart surgery-- like, urgently. The doctors told him that there was a problem with the largest blood vessel in his heart, his aorta, that if they didn't replace part of it, that it could burst and kill him.
郑重声明，这在科学上是不正确的，Seth自己也知道。起搏器不会影响你的哭泣能力。但几个月前，Seth发现自己需要进行心脏直视手术——而且很紧急。医生告诉他，他心脏中最大的血管，即主动脉出了问题，如果不更换部分血管，它可能会破裂并要了他的命。
Seth didn't cry about it. Instead, he told all of us at work about it in the most casual way possible. He messaged us all on Slack. And he said, quote, "hey, if things go pear shaped, it's been fun." But after the surgery, he woke up in the hospital on heavy painkillers. And it wasn't until about five days later that it all hit him.
Seth没有因此哭泣。相反，他以一种尽可能随意的口吻告诉了我们所有人。他在Slack上发消息说，引用一下：“嘿，如果情况变得糟糕，那这段时间过得很开心。”但在手术后，他在重度止痛药的作用下在医院醒来。直到大约五天后，一切才击中了他。
I was writing a note on my phone, a Mother's Day note to my wife, Gabrielle. And I was typing in the Notes app alone in my hospital room. I was writing about my appreciation for her as a mother to our kids and as a partner. And I was absolutely overcome and started weeping.
当时我正用手机写便条，写给妻子Gabrielle的母亲节贺卡。我独自在病房的便签应用里打字。我写着作为孩子们的母亲和我的伴侣，我有多么感激她。我完全被淹没了，开始泪流满面。
Oh, man.
天哪。
Yeah, I started crying. And I also had the feeling of, oh my gosh, I'm crying. I'm alone. No one's here to see this. Gabrielle isn't here to witness this. So I pulled out my phone to try to capture this moment, like seeing a Bigfoot in the woods, trying to get it on film.
是的，我开始哭。我还产生了一种感觉：天哪，我在哭。我是一个人。没人在看。Gabrielle不在这儿见证这一幕。所以我拿出手机想捕捉这一刻，就像在大森林里看到大脚怪一样，试图把它拍下来。
It's so funny to me that you were like, no one's here to see this. That was the thought that popped into your brain.
你当时竟然想“没人在看”，这太搞笑了。
Yeah. I was like, of course I'm alone. No one's going to believe me.
是的。我想，当然我是一个人。没人会相信我的。
I have seen this video Seth took of himself crying. And I gotta say, this is no single thug tier kind of joint. Like, Seth was ugly crying. I'm not going to play it, though. Because it-- I don't know-- just feels a little too vulnerable to share. Seth did share the video with his wife, though. She was moved by it, glad for him. And ever since then, Seth's been thinking about that cry, how those tears just rolled on out, how he had no control and was just overcome.
我看过Seth自己拍的那段哭泣视频。我必须说，那不是什么那种只是流一滴眼泪的时刻。Seth是那种丑哭的样子。不过我不会播放它。因为……我不知道……我觉得分享这个有点太脆弱了。不过Seth把视频分享给了他妻子。她被感动了，为他感到高兴。从那以后，Seth一直思考着那次哭泣，那些眼泪是怎么流出来的，他怎么会失去控制，完全被淹没了。
But here's the thing. Seth hasn't cried since. And recently, he's been wondering, was that it? Was this just another freak crying accident that will likely never happen again?
但问题是，Seth之后再也没哭过。最近，他在想，那是唯一的一次吗？那仅仅是另一次偶然的、可能再也不会发生的哭泣事故吗？
My hope is that this wasn't just a window, but I don't know. I think it was probably the extremity of the surgery, just the pure gratitude for still being alive. So I hope I will cry more, but I do think it's possible that this was just such an extreme situation that that was a little bit--
我希望那不仅仅是个窗口，但我不知道。我想那可能是手术带来的极致情绪，纯粹是对活着充满感激。所以我希望我会哭得更多，但我确实认为，这可能只是因为处于极端境况下的一点点……
That that was the thing and that--
你是说那就是那回事，然后……
Yeah, that was the moment.
是的，那是那一刻。
Hmm. OK. Well, so you've come to the right place. And I say that because I want to find out if this was a window for you, if this was a one-time thing. And to help us do that, your coworkers and I created a set of triggers for you.
嗯，好吧。那么，你找对地方了。我这么说是因为我想弄清楚那对你来说是不是一个窗口，那是否是一次性的事情。为了帮我们完成这个，你的同事和我为你准备了一套触发机制。
[LAUGHS] Are you serious?
[笑声] 你是认真的吗？
I'm dead serious. I spent hours yesterday compiling a list of things that make us cry. So we're going to start with our first one.
我是绝对认真的。我昨天花了好几个小时整理了一份让我们哭泣的事情列表。所以我们要从第一个开始。
Yeah. We're doing this now?
好吧。我们现在就要做这个吗？
Oh. Yeah, we're doing this now.
噢。是的，我们现在就要做这个。
Oh, wow. OK.
哦，哇。好吧。
Is that OK?
可以吗？
Yeah, yeah. I just-- I feel so-- it feels so unlikely that I'm going to cry. And I feel bad for my-- in the future.
可以，可以。我只是——我感觉……我真的觉得我会哭的概率很小。我为我的未来感到担心。
Don't feel bad.
别担心。
OK. All right. Yes.
好的。好吧。是的。
So Level 1-- so, obviously, it's June. And this time of year, we have a lot of graduations from college, from high school. And there is literally this trend online of people posting graduations. And I just want to show you this.
第一级——很明显，现在是六月。每年的这个时候，我们有很多大学和高中的毕业典礼。网上有一个趋势，就是人们发布毕业典礼的视频。我想给你看看这个。
OK.
好的。
[BACKGROUND CHATTER]
[背景杂音]
You want to describe what you're seeing?
你想描述一下你看到的内容吗？
I'm seeing a graduate. It's like a high school graduate. Oh, he's putting his own gown onto his dad.
我看到一个毕业生。看起来是个高中毕业生。哦，他正把自己的毕业袍穿在他爸爸身上。
Yeah.
是的。
I feel so confused.
我感到很困惑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Is the dad graduating? Is he thanking him?
是爸爸毕业了吗？还是他在感谢他？
No, the kid is graduating, but he's saying I did it because of you. You really deserve this. Why is this making you laugh?
不，是孩子毕业了，但他在说“我做到了，是因为你。你确实配得上这个。”为什么这让你发笑？
No, I just-- I think I--
不，我只是——我想我……
I explained to Seth, look, most of these folks are immigrants. And what they're doing is, they're saying to their parents, listen, this accomplishment I just made, it's really yours.
我向Seth解释，看，这些人大多是移民。他们所做的是告诉他们的父母：“听着，我刚刚取得的这个成就，实际上是属于你们的。”
That's so sweet. I don't feel anywhere close to crying.
这太贴心了。但我没感觉到任何想哭的冲动。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I feel like-- yeah, I'm appreciating their emotion.
我觉得——是的，我很欣赏他们的情感。
It is OK that you didn't cry, Seth. You know why?
Seth，没哭是很正常的，你知道为什么吗？
Because there's more?
因为还有更多？
Because there's more.
因为还有更多。
Just to say, I had a bunch of videos cued and ready to go. I had Susan Boyle singing "I Dreamed a Dream" on Britain's Got Talent, which my coworkers want me to make clear makes me and only me cry. I had the ending to the randomly extremely violent children's movie about rabbits, Watership Down, the opening scene from the animated movie Up. But first, there was this next one. It was an old sports video.
顺便说一下，我本来准备好了一大堆视频。我有Susan Boyle在《英国达人秀》上唱《我曾有梦》，我的同事们坚持要我说明，这让我——且仅让我——哭泣。我还有那部极其暴力的兔子电影《瓦特希普高原》的结尾，动画电影《飞屋环游记》的开场片段。但首先，是接下来这个。这是一段古老的体育视频。
I want you to picture it. It's the 1992 Olympics, Barcelona. It's a 400-meter race. And this young British sprinter, Derek Redmond, is in the race of his life-- big deal. And the eyes of the world are watching him. So the race starts. OK, that's him right there, streaming away. It's looking pretty good.
我想请你想象一下。这是1992年巴塞罗那奥运会。是一场400米比赛。这位年轻的英国短跑运动员Derek Redmond正在参加他一生中最重要的一场比赛。全世界的目光都在注视着他。比赛开始了。好的，那就是他，正在飞奔。看起来很不错。
OK, white and purple.
好的，穿白紫色衣服的那个。
Yep, yep, yep.
是的，是的，是的。
He's doing-- OK.
他做得很好——好的。
Really great. It's 400, so he has to run all the way around. And then right here, his hamstring goes.
真的很棒。这是400米，所以他必须跑一整圈。就在这儿，他的腿筋拉伤了。
Oh, yeah.
噢，天哪。
Looks like a hamstring.
看起来像是腿筋。
Oh, jeez. Oh, he's down.
噢，天呐。噢，他倒下了。
So only a 40-second race-- all the other runners finish without him. And then he decides, oh, OK. I'm going to--
所以仅仅是40秒的比赛——所有其他选手都跑完了，但他没有。然后他决定，噢，好的。我要……
Oh, he's--
噢，他……
--keep on trying to finish.
……坚持试着跑完。
Oh, he's basically hopping on one foot, almost.
噢，他几乎是在用一只脚跳。
Yeah. He has no hamstring. Like, it's gone.
是的。他腿筋断了。像是没了。
Oh, god.
噢，上帝。
His effort--
他的努力——
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
All of a sudden, this guy comes up.
突然，这个人冲了上来。
Wow. He's like, being his crutch.
哇。他就像是他的拐杖。
That's Derek's father. He's run onto the track to make sure his son finishes.
那是Derek的父亲。他跑上赛道确保他的儿子跑完全程。
He's come down to help him.
他跑下来帮他了。
And it's funny because the security people, they don't know that it's his father. So they have come onto the track. And he's having to wave them away to keep them away from him. And he's like, I'm going to finish with my son. And this man is just-- he's collapsed in his father's arms, and they're finishing together.
有趣的是，安保人员不知道那是他父亲。所以他们冲到了赛道上。他不得不挥手让他们走开。他心想，我要和我的儿子一起冲过终点。这个男人……他倒在他父亲怀里，他们一起完成了比赛。
Oh my gosh. [SNIFFLING] [SIGHS] That was just--
天呐。[抽泣声] [叹气] 那真是……
Oh, Seth. I didn't think that was actually going to work.
噢，Seth。我真没想到那竟然真的奏效了。
I would have bet any amount of money it wouldn't. Wow. My mind is blown. My heart, I suppose, more specifically, is blown.
我本来愿意押上任何赌注说那不会发生的。哇。我的大脑被震住了。我想，准确地说，是我的心被震住了。
There's part of me, I have to say, even as I am feeling uncomfortable and sad and kind of crying myself-- there's part of me, I got to say, that is just like, did you actually just cry for real?
我必须说，尽管我感到不舒服、难过，甚至自己也快要哭了，但我内心有一部分在想：你真的哭了吗？
Yeah, I mean I think I-- Yeah, I want to be really honest, because I think I was trying to feel open to it. And so I think I could have not. I could have stopped it. And maybe that's something I would actually do without knowing it. But then I actually felt it, and I still sort of am. Like, it's-- I don't know what's happening. It just feels like feeling.
是的，我是说，我想……我想诚实一点，因为我觉得当时我确实试图让自己保持开放。所以我认为我本可以不哭的。我本可以阻止它。也许这真的是我无意识中会做的事情。但后来我确实感受到了，而且我现在仍然处于这种感觉中。这……我不知道发生了什么。这感觉就像是一种情绪。
I'm so glad for you. What about that video do you think made you cry?
我真为你高兴。你认为那段视频里是什么让你哭了？
I think it was seeing-- he's in so much physical pain. And he's in so much, I imagine, emotional pain at losing this shot. But I feel like, through that, you can see he's also crying from joy that his father is there. And then shift my vision to the dad, who is waving away these security people and is being relatively stoic, but is also clearly overcome in his own way.
我想是看到他承受着巨大的身体痛苦。我想他因为错失了这个机会也承受着巨大的情感痛苦。但我感觉，通过这一切，你可以看到他也在为父亲的到来而喜悦。然后我把视线移到他父亲身上，他正在挥手驱赶那些安保人员，表现得相对坚毅，但显然也以自己的方式被感动了。
I think it just, it felt both kind of tragic and so victorious at the same moment. And it got to me. And I can't-- yeah, I still can't quite believe it.
我认为那一刻既悲壮又胜利，简直就在同一瞬间。它触动了我。而且我无法——是的，我还是有点不敢相信。
As I sat there, listening to this grown man who almost never cried in his adult life struggle to find the words, his eyes still slightly watering, I didn't know what to say. I just started sniffling, which is normally what happens when someone cries in front of me.
当我坐在那儿，听着这个几乎从未在大人的生活中哭过的成年男人努力寻找词汇，他的眼睛依然微微湿润，我不知道该说什么。我只是开始抽泣，这通常是别人在我面前哭时我的反应。
I am, for the record, a crier. But I'm really just a crier because I often find it easier than saying the right thing. For me, crying is like a shortcut, the best way to let the people in my life know that I love them and that I care. And it struck me that, for years, Seth hasn't had that. And now, well, he does.
郑重声明，我确实是个爱哭的人。但我爱哭真的只是因为我发现这通常比说正确的话更容易。对我来说，哭是一种捷径，是让生命中关心的人知道我爱他们、我在乎他们的最好方式。让我印象深刻的是，Seth多年来都没有这种表达方式。而现在，好吧，他有了。
Act Three, Benched Expectations. So like I said earlier, championship windows are these periods when the universe has conspired to make it so that, for once, everything might go right. And this last story is about a very particular version of that. It's about two baseball teams who, I should say, were not playing for a championship. They were doing kind of the opposite, actually. They were playing to finally not lose.
第三幕，板凳上的期望。正如我早些时候所说，夺冠窗口期是宇宙共谋促成的时期，让万事万物或许能有一次顺遂发展。最后一个故事关于这一概念的一个非常具体的版本。它是关于两支棒球队，我必须说明，他们不是为了冠军而战。事实上，他们正做着相反的事。他们是在为终于“不输”而战。
If you combine the records of these two teams, they'd lost 141 straight games between them-- 141. But now, the stars had aligned. Because after all those losses, after all that heartbreak, there was this little glint of hope. Because next on their schedule, those two teams were going to play each other, which meant, for one of them, the losing streak would finally have to end. There was no way around it. No matter how bad those teams were, one of them was going to win.
如果你把这两支球队的纪录加在一起，他们之间已经连输了141场比赛——141场。但现在，群星闪耀，机会来了。因为在经历了那么多次失败、那么多次心碎之后，有了一丝希望。因为在接下来的赛程中，这两支队伍要对垒，这意味着其中一支队伍的连败终于要终结了。这是无法避免的。无论这两支球队有多烂，其中一方总会赢。
My colleague, David Kestenbaum, talked to some of the players before this historic matchup. And then he went to the game to see how it all turned out. Here's David.
我的同事David Kestenbaum在历史性对决前采访了一些球员。然后他去现场看了比赛结果。这是David的报道。
I wanted to know what it was like to go so long without winning a single game. To not win and keep coming out, that takes a particular kind of person. Both teams are in New York City. I reached out, first to Yeshiva University. Their team, the Yeshiva Macabees-- Yeshiva's losing streak was at 99 games. And I know everyone knows how to add 1, but for them to lose would mean 100 straight losses. Yeshiva did not want to talk to us for this story, which I will just say, I get.
我想知道，长久以来一场比赛都不赢是什么感觉。如果不赢球还要坚持上场，那需要一种特别的人。这两支球队都在纽约市。我首先联系了叶史瓦大学（Yeshiva University）。他们的球队，叶史瓦马卡比队——叶史瓦的连败纪录是99场。我知道每个人都知道1+1等于几，但对于他们来说，输了就意味着100连败。叶史瓦不想接受我们的采访，我必须说，我理解。
But the other team said OK, the Lehman Lightning, who had 42 straight losses. Lehman College is in the Bronx. It's part of the City University system. So I went to visit. And I want you to meet one player, Justin Chamarro, the starting pitcher.
但另一支球队说了可以，莱曼闪电队（Lehman Lightning），他们连输了42场。莱曼学院位于布朗克斯，是纽约市立大学系统的一部分。所以我去拜访了他们。我想让你们认识一名球员，Justin Chamarro，首发投手。
Justin has a kind of shy smile. When we started texting, he wrote, "Heyyy DAVID!!" Three Ys, David in caps, two exclamation points. His team hasn't won in two years. And I know all the stuff people say about how losing builds character and bonds you together with your team and teaches you life lessons-- I mean, sure. But also-- and I appreciated Justin's candor here-- it is not fun.
Justin有一种腼腆的微笑。当我们开始发短信时，他写道：“嘿——David！！”三个Y，大写David，两个感叹号。他的球队已经两年没赢过了。我知道人们常说失败如何磨练性格、团结团队并传授人生道理——我是说，当然。但同时——我很欣赏Justin在这里的坦率——这真的不开心。
I've never been in this long of a losing streak a day in my life. It's actually depressing. No, let me stop. But it's hard. It's difficult. I say it challenges me mentally, physically. It's draining. It's really draining.
我这辈子从来没经历过这么长的连败。这真的让人沮丧。不，等一下。但确实很难。很难。我说这在精神上、身体上都在挑战我。这很消耗人。真的让人筋疲力尽。
Yeah. Say more. Like, I don't know, how'd you feel after the last loss?
是的。再多说点。比如，上次输球后你感觉如何？
The last loss weighed on me heavy because Mount St. Mary, they're a good school, but we also competed to their level. Playing games like that, where you're constantly in a game and then you just lose it, that's exhausting. That's what sucks out of everything, honestly.
最后那场失利让我感到沉重，因为圣玛丽山学院是一所很好的学校，但我们也和他们水平相当。打这种比赛，你一直处于竞争中，然后却输掉了，这让人精疲力尽。老实说，这真的很折磨人。
It's not just him going through this. It's a whole team that every game says to themselves "this time" and then has it not happen.
经历这一切的不止他一个人。整个球队在每场比赛都对自己说“就这一次”，然后却没能实现。
There's a lot of frustration. You have people upset at themselves, the coach. There's a lot of stuff like that. But in the locker rooms also, it's very quiet. It's an eerie atmosphere in the locker room, honestly. But we pick each other up. That's what we do.
挫败感非常多。你会有人对自己感到愤怒，对教练也是。有很多那种事。但在更衣室里，也非常安静。说实话，更衣室里的气氛很怪。但我们会互相鼓劲。这就是我们要做的。
A bunch of people on campus must know about the streak, right?
校园里很多人肯定都知道连败的事，对吧？
Yeah, I'm pretty sure everybody knows about the streak. [LAUGHS] I'm pretty sure. I mean, it's no secret. There's multiple videos out there and media outlets that highlight it.
是的，我肯定每个人都知道连败的事。[笑声] 我确定。我的意思是，这不是什么秘密。网上有很多视频和媒体报道都在强调这件事。
He's talking about the upcoming game. The internet liked the idea that his team was going to play this other losing team. One post called it the worst college baseball game of all time. I asked Justin why, when the other team did not want to talk, he was willing to. He said he wanted the world to know who they really were.
他指的是接下来的比赛。网络很喜欢他这支队伍即将挑战另一支连败球队的想法。一篇帖子称之为史上最烂的大学棒球赛。我问Justin，为什么另一支球队拒绝采访，他却愿意。他说他想让世界知道他们真实的样子。
So here's a little bit about Justin. In his bedroom, he has the following-- a poster of Muhammad Ali, an Xbox, shoes, a bag filled with baseballs from the best games he's played in, one from when he was 11-- oh, and textbooks. He's a bio major, planning to be a physician's assistant after all this is over, maybe work in a clinic. He said, that's my second love.
这就是Justin的情况。在他的卧室里，有以下物品——一张穆罕默德·阿里的海报、一台Xbox、鞋子、一个装满他参加过最好比赛的棒球的包，其中一个还是他11岁时的——噢，还有教科书。他是生物专业的，计划在这一切结束后当一名内科助理，或许在诊所工作。他说，那是我的第二真爱。
What's your first love? Baseball.
那你第一真爱是什么？棒球。
Oh, I love baseball with a passion, yes.
噢，我非常热爱棒球，是的。
Since you were little?
从你小时候开始？
Oh, since I could remember, yeah.
噢，只要我有记忆以来就是，是的。
What do you like about it?
你喜欢它什么？
Well, I like how competitive it gets. I like the fact that it's a game based off of failure and that when you actually succeed, it feels that much better.
嗯，我喜欢它的竞争感。我喜欢它是一个基于“失败”的游戏，当你真的成功时，那种感觉会好得多。
Yeah. They say, if you get up at bat and you fail seven times out of 10, you're doing great, right?
是的。人们常说，如果你上场击球，十次里失败七次，你就算表现得很好了，对吧？
Yes.
是的。
That's a tough proposition, you know?
这可是个艰难的命题，你知道吗？
Yeah, it is. It is. I mean, essentially, you're failing more than you succeed. But you got to look at it on the bright side. You're also playing a sport that involves a tiny little ball with a round bat, and you have nine fielders. So yeah.
是的，是这样。我的意思是，本质上，你失败的次数比成功的次数多。但你得往好处看。你也在玩一项涉及一个小球和一个圆木棒，而且有九个防守球员的运动。所以，是的。
Funny to think about it that way. Justin says he does sometimes to remind himself it's just a game-- a very hard one. So what do you do to turn things around? This is a Division III commuter school. Most of these students live with their families. A lot of the players have jobs in addition to school.
这样想很有趣。Justin说他有时会这样做，提醒自己这只是一场游戏——一项非常难的游戏。那你做什么来扭转局面？这是一所通勤大学（Division III）。大多数学生和家人住在一起。很多球员除了上学还有工作。
Justin wanted me to point that out. He also wanted me to point out that there is not a big budget for baseball here-- no scholarships for players, no batting cages or pitching machines to practice hitting with. But they practice almost every day, sometimes for hours. The truth is, it's probably their last chance to play like this, with a coach and a real team.
Justin想让我指出这一点。他还想让我指出，学校里没有多少棒球预算——没有奖学金，没有击球笼或投球机来练习击球。但他们几乎每天都练习，有时长达数小时。事实是，这可能是他们像这样打球的最后机会了，有教练和一个真正的团队。
This is a moment in their lives that will end. No one is going on to the pros. And for Justin, this is his senior year, almost the end of the season. And it would feel different to go out with one win. So to try to turn things around, their coach, Coach Delgado, gives them grades after every game. He has them write in journals about what they did well and what they need to work on.
这是他们生命中终将结束的一刻。没人会去打职业赛。对Justin来说，这是他的大四，赛季快结束了。如果能以一场胜利结束，感觉会不一样。所以为了尝试扭转局面，他们的教练Delgado教练在每场比赛后给他们打分。他让他们写日记，记录自己做得好的地方和需要改进的地方。
And they are not a superstitious bunch, but it's kind of hard not to be a little, after a streak like they're on. Your brain is looking for some reason. Justin's coach eats the same breakfast before every game. The players do not step on the lines before a game. That's a classic. They also do not allow crossed bats in the dugout.
他们不是那种迷信的群体，但在经历这样的连败后，很难不迷信一点。你的大脑一直在寻找某种原因。Justin的教练每场比赛前吃一样的早餐。球员们在比赛前不踩界线。这是经典的迷信。他们也不允许在休息区里交叉球棒。
I know we've tried playing without walk-up songs.
我知道我们尝试过没有“上场音乐”打球。
Walk-up songs-- you know, when the hitter's walking out to the plate. They used to play a clip of a song through the loudspeakers to get them psyched up. Got rid of those.
上场音乐——你知道，击球手走到击球区时。他们过去常通过扩音器播放一段音乐来振奋精神。现在取消了。
Yeah, so it's just silent at home games.
是的，所以主场比赛时静悄悄的。
How did it feel the first time?
第一次感觉如何？
I was kind of mad because I liked my walk-out song.
我很生气，因为我喜欢我的上场音乐。
What's your song?
你的歌是什么？
One is "I'm Good" by David Guetta. And it's, I'm good and I'm feeling all right. I'mma have the best time of my life-- yeah, that's that song.
一个是David Guetta的《I'm Good》。歌词是“我很好，我感觉一切都好。我会度过我一生中最美好的时光”——是的，就是那首歌。
That song, you won't be hearing. Other songs you won't be hearing-- "Lemonade" by Gucci Mane, "Nokia" by Drake.
那首歌，你听不到了。其他你也听不到的歌还有——Gucci Mane的《Lemonade》，Drake的《Nokia》。
Do you think about how it's going to feel when you eventually win?
你有没有想过最终赢球时是什么感觉？
Oh, I think about it every single day. One streak has to end. And I'm very confident that ours will end tomorrow.
噢，我每天都在想。连败终会终结。我非常有信心，明天我们的连败就会终结。
Now let's play ball.
现在，让我们开始比赛吧。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
Game time. It's a Tuesday, 2:00 in the afternoon at a turf field in New Jersey, far from both schools. And yet, so many people-- like, 300-- some baseball nerds, drawn, I think, by the strangeness of the situation. It kind of went viral online, these two teams that had together lost 141 games about to play each other. One of them had to finally win.
比赛时间。这是一个周二下午2点，在纽约以外新泽西的一个人造草皮球场。然而，有那么多人——大约300人——一些棒球极客，我想是因为这种局面的奇特性而吸引来的。这件事在网上疯传，这两支合计输掉141场的队伍即将交手。其中一支终于要赢了。
I had no idea how this was going to go. No one seemed to.
我完全不知道比赛会如何进行。没人知道。
YU, YU, YU.
YU, YU, YU。
Mostly, the people who show up are fans. Some have never been to a game before. Lots of Yeshiva supporters, hoping the 99 losses would not turn into 100.
来的人大多是球迷。有些人从没看过棒球比赛。有很多叶史瓦的支持者，希望99连败不会变成100连败。
Do you have any cheers? No cheers?
你们有什么助威口号吗？没有？
We're going to make them up on the fly. YU. YU. YU. YU. YU.
我们要临时想一个。YU，YU，YU，YU，YU。
And plenty of Lehman fans-- here's one. Franchesca Angeles came to support one player in particular, the shortstop. He's her boyfriend.
还有很多莱曼的支持者——给你们介绍一个。Franchesca Angeles来支持某一位特定球员，即游击手。他是她的男朋友。
It's funny. He sleeps, he eats, and he talks baseball. [LAUGHS] Like, he dreams baseball. I'm telling you, it's funny. Sometimes he will flinch. He's sleeping. And I'm like, what's happening? He's like, I'm getting a grounder ball. [LAUGHS] So yeah, he's in the game, always.
这很有趣。他睡觉、吃饭、说话都是棒球。[笑声] 就像他梦见棒球一样。我告诉你，这很有趣。有时他会抽动。他在睡觉。我就问：“发生什么事了？”他说：“我接到一个滚地球。”[笑声] 所以，是的，他一直都在比赛中。
I settled in on the Lehman side, right up against the fence near the dugout. The game starts and immediately does not go well for Lehman. Yeshiva, the other team, is at bat. One of their players hits the ball deep. But the fielder is there.
我在莱曼这一边靠着休息区附近的栅栏坐下。比赛开始，对莱曼来说立刻就不太顺利。叶史瓦，另一支队伍，正在击球。他们其中一名球员把球打得很远。但防守队员在那里。
It's going to be a flyout.
这会是一个高飞球出局。
Should be an out.
应该是个出局。
Oh, there it is.
噢，就在那儿。
Get out of here. He missed it.
滚出来。他错过了。
He missed it.
他错过了。
That right there should have been caught.
那本来应该接住的。
Then another ball hit in the air.
然后又是一个飞向空中的球。
Oh, that should be a routiner.
噢，那应该是个常规球。
Let's see if he makes it.
看看他能不能接住。
[GROANS]
[呻吟声]
Man, que malo.
天呐，真烂。
So yeah.
所以，是的。
The guy narrating here is a former Lehman player named Erik Then who'd come to watch the game with his girlfriend. He knows Justin and all the players. Right after that, another mistake-- Yeshiva scores. It kept going.
这里的叙述者是前莱曼球员Erik Then，他和女朋友来看比赛。他认识Justin和所有的球员。就在那之后，又犯了一个错——叶史瓦得分了。这种情况一直在继续。
Oh, that should be a routine out. Oh.
噢，那应该是个常规出局。噢。
[CROWD SHOUTING]
[观众叫喊]
And that's an error right there.
在那儿有个失误。
Do they look nervous to you?
他们看起来紧张吗？
Oh, yeah, definitely. [LAUGHS] And another one scores.
噢，是的，绝对。[笑声] 又得一分。
Yeshiva scores again. So it's 2-0. And if you're thinking, oh, I know how this will go. Justin's team will bounce back. Can I remind you this is real life, a tiny ball, a round bat, and all that? And that is Justin out there pitching, a real human being. The Lehman players do score one in the next inning. Both teams actually play pretty solidly once they settle in. There's some truly incredible moments.
叶史瓦再次得分。比分变成2-0。如果你在想，噢，我知道接下来会怎样，Justin的球队会反弹。我可以提醒你，这是现实生活，一个小球、一个圆木棒，还有所有那些因素吗？Justin在外面投球，他是一个真实的人类。莱曼球员在下一局确实得了一分。两队在稳定下来后打得都很扎实。有一些真正令人难以置信的时刻。
That was an amazing play right there. That's like ESPN top 10 right there.
那是个精彩的配合。那绝对是ESPN前10的水平。
But by the end, going into the last inning, Lehman is still behind. The score is 6-4. They have this one last at bat, and they need to score two runs to tie it up. They do get a runner on first. Then this guy, Eli, steps up to bat.
但到最后，进入最后一局，莱曼仍然落后。比分是6-4。他们有最后一次击球机会，需要得两分才能追平。他们确实有一个跑垒员到了二垒。然后这个叫Eli的人上场击球。
Let's go, Eli. Nueva York. Yo, Eli, tie this shit. Let's go. One swing, baby. Right field. Yeah!
加油，Eli。纽约。嘿，Eli，把这烂摊子扳平。加油。一击，宝贝。右外野。耶！
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
[SPEAKING SPANISH] New Jersey.
[西班牙语] 新泽西。
The pitcher walked him.
投球手保送了他。
It's a huge moment right now, right? So somehow, some way, right now, he's got to make something happen with that bat.
这是一个巨大的时刻，对吧？所以某种程度上，现在，他必须在那根木棒上做点什么。
Next batter steps up to the plate--
下一位击球手走上击球区——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The pitch--
投球——
Yeah, let's go! Let's go! So right there, hit by a pitch. Now it's at bases loaded right now. This pitcher's obviously flustered up right now.
是的，加油！加油！就是那样，投球击中了他。现在是满垒了。投手显然心烦意乱。
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
加油。加油。加油。加油。
They get a hit.
他们击出了球。
Oh, let's go!
噢，加油！
The runner on third races to home plate and scores. And then another runner scores.
三垒上的跑垒员冲向本垒得分了。然后另一个也得分了。
Yeah! Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
耶！加油。加油。加油。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
[YELLING]
[大喊声]
Let's go. Now they just tied the game up right now.
加油。现在比分扳平了。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
My boy!
我的兄弟！
They need one more run to win. The shortstop, number 18, who, remember, fields grounders in his sleep, gives a look to his girlfriend, steps up to the plate.
他们还需要一分才能赢。游击手，18号，记住，他在睡梦中都在防滚地球的那位，看了女朋友一眼，走向击球区。
Do you know this guy?
你认识这人吗？
Yes, I definitely do. Let's go, one eight!
是的，我很确定。加油，一八！
Did you say let's go, honey?
你是说“加油，亲爱的”吗？
No, let's go, one eight. But yeah, that is my honey. [LAUGHS]
不，是“加油，一八”。但是的，那确实是我的亲爱的。[笑声]
One eight-- that's his number, 18. He grounds out, though. So the game is still tied. And it ends up going to an extra inning. Lehman scores one to put them ahead, and then Yeshiva steps up to bat. Lehman just has to keep Yeshiva from scoring one last time. They get the first batter out and the second batter.
一八——那是他的号码，18。不过他最后打出了滚地球出局。所以比赛仍然是平局。最后进入了加时局。莱曼得了一分领先，然后叶史瓦上场击球。莱曼只要阻止叶史瓦再得最后一分就行了。他们让第一名击球手出局，第二名也出局。
Let's go, Justin. Let's go, two eight.
加油，Justin。加油，二八。
And then Justin, who is still pitching-- has been pitching the entire game-- faces batter number 3. One strike, two strikes. And--
然后一直投球——整场比赛都在投球的Justin，面对第三名击球手。一个好球，两个好球。而且——
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
--struck him out. Lehman won.
——三振出局。莱曼赢了。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
All right, and that's the game-- walk off right there.
好的，比赛结束了——直接结束比赛。
Chris, our impromptu narrator, and his girlfriend kiss in celebration, the way I think people do when wars end. It just feels like the thing to do. I walk out onto the field to find Justin, the pitcher, whose hand was actually bleeding-- seemed appropriate.
我们的临时叙述者Chris和他的女朋友在庆祝中接吻，我觉得那是人们在战争结束后会做的事情。这感觉就是该做的事。我走到球场上找到投手Justin，他的手实际上正在流血——看起来挺合适的。
In the middle of the game while I was pitching, I snapped a curveball a little too tight. And I guess I cut myself. And that's what happened. And I just kept playing with it.
比赛中途我投球时，曲线球握得太紧了。我想我割伤了自己。就是这样。但我坚持打完了比赛。
How you feel?
你感觉怎么样？
I'm so excited. I'm so happy. I'm jumping for joy on the inside. This doesn't do justice as to how I feel. I just wish my parents were here to see it.
我太兴奋了。我太开心了。我内心在欢呼。这不足以表达我的感受。我只希望我父母能在这儿看到这一幕。
They were at work. Remember, it's a Tuesday afternoon. So the Lehman streak was broken. And for the Yeshiva Maccabees, their streak was now at 100 straight losses. But at some point, that will end, probably. It has to, right? Sometime, the universe will shift. The stars and the planets will be in the right spot. The ball will take that weird hop that gets you an extra run. They'll get their championship window.
他们当时在上班。记住，这是周二下午。所以莱曼的连败被终结了。而对于叶史瓦马卡比队，他们的连败现在是100场。但总有一天，这会终结，大概吧。总会终结的，对吧？总有一天，宇宙会发生变化。恒星和行星会在正确的位置。球会有一个奇怪的跳动，让你多得一分。他们会拥有自己的夺冠窗口。
In fact, did I tell you this was a double header? Lehman and Yeshiva had a second game to play against each other. Here's what happened. After the first game, almost everyone left. It was getting late and super cold. One person on the way to their car pointed out that Yeshiva had run through, like, four pitchers. So who could they possibly have left? There didn't seem to be much point.
事实上，我告诉过你们这是一场双重赛吗？莱曼和叶史瓦还要打第二场比赛。这是之后发生的事。第一场比赛后，几乎所有人都离开了。天色已晚且非常冷。有人在去车里的路上指出，叶史瓦已经用掉了四个投手。他们还能剩谁？看起来没什么看头。
But the two teams played again. And somehow, Yeshiva, after 100 straight losses, they won-- finally.
但两队又打了一场。不知为何，叶史瓦在100连败后，他们赢了——终于。
[CROWD CHEERING]
[观众欢呼]
The championship window had opened for both of them.
两个队的夺冠窗口都打开了。
That's the game, folks. Final score--
比赛结束，伙计们。最终比分——
And then it closed. Turns out, it was the only win either team would have for the rest of the season. They both went on to lose every remaining game. Justin, the Lehman pitcher, graduated the other week. He told me he still thinks about that game, their one win. He can replay every pitch in his mind. His fingers felt warm and tingly, like every pitch he threw was going to be perfect.
然后窗口又关上了。事实证明，这是两队在赛季剩余比赛中唯一的一场胜利。他们此后输掉了所有剩余的比赛。莱曼的投手Justin前几天毕业了。他告诉我他仍然会想起那场比赛，那是他们唯一的一场胜利。他可以在脑海里重播每一球。他的手指感觉温暖而刺痛，就像他投出的每一球都将是完美的一样。
You could say the stars were aligned that day. But there's another way to see it. The stars had nothing to do with it. They made it happen.
你可以说那天群星闪耀。但还有另一种看法。这与群星无关。是他们促成了这一切。
["TAKE ME OUT TO THE BALL GAME" BY MATT PETERS, MATT SCHELLENBERG]
David Kestenbaum-- he's the senior editor of our show. So there is, of course, one last piece of business that I have to take care of, I guess, which is-- I got to tell you that Arsenal, my favorite soccer team, the ones who were in that game I was watching in the bar at the beginning of the show-- they lost. We ended the season with nothing, again.
David Kestenbaum——他是我们节目的资深编辑。当然，我还有最后一件事要处理，我想是这样——我得告诉你们，阿森纳，我最喜欢的足球队，也就是我在节目开头看的比赛里的那支球队——他们输了。我们再次一无所获地结束了赛季。
And on the way out of the bar that day, I ran into a couple of Arsenal fans arguing about the state of the team. The inquest had well and truly begun.
那天离开酒吧时，我遇到一对正在争论球队状况的阿森纳球迷。调查确实已经正式开始了。
I think we were the better side today.
我认为今天我们表现得更好。
You have copium out the ass. We were not the better side today.
你满口都是借口。我们今天表现得并不更好。
The first half-- we had them on the ropes for, I would say, the first--
上半场——我可以说，我们把他们逼到了绝境……
So yeah. Folks were reacting to the loss in different ways. But in the last couple of weeks, there have been whispers about new star players who could join Arsenal next season. And the thing I keep hearing from my fellow Arsenal fans is genuine excitement for what might happen.
所以，是的。人们以不同的方式对这次失利做出反应。但在过去几周，有传言说有新的明星球员可能在下赛季加入阿森纳。我从阿森纳球迷同僚那里一直听到的，是对未来可能发生之事的由衷兴奋。
["GAME WINNER" BY VULFPECK]
Our program was produced today by Angela Gervasi and me and edited by Emanuele Berry. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, and our managing editor, Sarah Abdurrahman. The version of "Take Me Out to the Ball Game" you heard in David Kestenbaum's story was made for us by Matt Peters and Matt Schellenberg. You can find their music at deadmenmusic.com.
我们的节目由Angela Gervasi和我制作，Emanuele Berry编辑。参与制作今天节目的还有Phia Bennin、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Cassie Howley、Seth Lind、Tobin Low、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson、Nadia Reiman、Anthony Roman、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Christopher Swetala、Marisa Robertson-Textor，以及我们的总编辑Sarah Abdurrahman。你在David Kestenbaum的故事中听到的《带我去棒球赛》版本是由Matt Peters和Matt Schellenberg为我们制作的。你可以在deadmenmusic.com找到他们的音乐。
Special thanks today goes to Abi Adamson, Peter Sotiri, Tan Copsey, Sophia Mussa, Sena Dzotsi, Jason Andrew, and everybody over at the Brooklyn Invincibles. Special thanks also to the two Arsenal bars where I camped out for a couple of weeks for this episode, Highbury Pub and Fancy Free. Special thanks as well to Daniel Malamud, author of the recently released book, This is Football, a must read. And thanks again to Belle Woods, Dana Leigh Marks, Rowan Groom, Lindsey Gauzza, Kristin Kepplinger, Benjamin Remy, Allison Cutler, Eric Brooks, and Qing Li.
特别感谢Abi Adamson、Peter Sotiri、Tan Copsey、Sophia Mussa、Sena Dzotsi、Jason Andrew以及Brooklyn Invincibles的所有人。还要特别感谢我为本集节目蹲守了几周的两家阿森纳酒吧，Highbury Pub和Fancy Free。还要特别感谢最近发布的新书《这就是足球》(This is Football) 的作者Daniel Malamud，这是一本必读之作。再次感谢Belle Woods、Dana Leigh Marks、Rowan Groom、Lindsey Gauzza、Kristin Kepplinger、Benjamin Remy、Allison Cutler、Eric Brooks和Qing Li。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free, and there's videos and lists of favorite shows and tons of other stuff there too-- again, that's thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案，那里还有视频、最喜爱节目列表和大量其他内容——再说一次，那是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）提供给公共广播电台。
And thanks, as always, to my boss, the big man, Ira Glass. You know, when we first started working on this episode, he found it really surprising when I suggested that I be the host. I swear, every day, over and over, he just kept asking--
也像往常一样感谢我的老板，那个大人物，Ira Glass。你知道，当我们刚开始制作这一集时，他发现我提议自己主持时感到非常惊讶。我发誓，每天，一次又一次，他一直在问——
Y U. Y U. Y U.
YU, YU, YU。
I'm Emmanuel Dzotsi. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Emmanuel Dzotsi。Ira Glass将于下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
["GAME WINNER" BY VULFPECK]